[Música]
o meu antecessor ad ele já até falou que
será que o aos universitários estão
preocupadas com gênero porque será que
eu estou aqui pra falar de gênero de
igualdade de gêneros
o empoderamento da mulher porque não
veio falar sobre a transplante de útero
o que gerou um um filho ou então da da
proteína que é retarda a o progresso de
uma das células cancerígenas ou então de
materiais inteligentes porque esse é um
problema é um problema da sociedade e é
dever da universidade de pesquisa
encarar os problemas também na
universidade pesquisa não forma apenas
os bons profissionais
ou então desenvolve pesquisas que tenha
ferreira percussão muito grande melhora
a qualidade de vida
o adversário também tem obrigação de
estudar os problemas da sociedade ver as
causas propor soluções recomendar
políticas públicas
a questão de gênero ainda é um problema
a minha geração eu sou um dos mais
velhos aqui viu avanços muito grandes
vocês podem não acreditar mas era
verdade na década de 70
mulher não podia entrar em túlio em
obras os operários imediatamente paravam
trabalho e fugiam
porque mulher afinal the mall ouro
parece medieval mas acontecia há 40 anos
atrás
aqui no estado de são paulo na cidade de
são paulo metrô um túnel
então as minhas colegas não podiam fazer
as visitas com a gente
vinte anos depois uma grande rodovia que
foi construída com vários túneis foi
coordenada por uma engenheira não houve
progresso mas ainda não o suficiente
e 2014
a universal em são paulo teve a honra de
ser convidada pela onu mulheres para
participar do programa da iniciativa he
forte
são dez universidades
a unidade de são paulo é uma delas a
única da américa latina
dez empresas nenhuma brasileira
lamentavelmente e 10 países brasil
incluído a usp foi convidada
provavelmente que nós já tínhamos ações
pró ativas na na discussão do gênero e
com essa esse convite
nós nos sentimos na obrigação de
acelerar mais as atividades relativas a
primeira coisa como é diz citou para
vocês nós antes do que escolas nós
abrimos um escritório os de mulheres que
hoje é coordenada pela professora eva
blog e se os escritórios e mulheres é a
função principal de melhorar os
relacionamentos dentro da comunidade
acadêmica alunos professores
funcionários uma tarefa difícil
além disso a primeira coisa que nós
fizemos também foi combater a violência
e combatemos a violência com várias
frentes convênio com a polícia
treinamento da guarda universitária e
tecnologia os nossos principais campi
têm câmera em todo lugar
temos aplicativos que pelo celular as
pessoas indicam ao risco então a
preocupação que tem infelizmente com
isso a violência foi pelo menos será
dada este ano não tivemos nenhum caso
mas isso também não é suficiente
precisamos criar a cultura de que o
respeito ao outro gênero faz parte da
sociedade e isso nós estamos fazendo os
nossos alunos através de atividades
esportivas sócio culturais usando
estuprar socialização dos alunos e
mostrando a necessidade do respeito
mútuo são grandes avanços mas
continuamos com a necessidade de mais
ações pra liderança das mulheres na
sociedade
isso é uma coisa fundamental eu quero
mostrar um é uma coisa interessante que
aconteceu aqui na usp
nos últimos cinco anos
primeiro o número de alunos e alunas nós
sempre tivemos equilibrado apenas na
última década os 15 anos e equilibrado
50% e 50% inclusive inclusive nos
últimos anos a pós-graduação nós temos
mais alunas do que alunos
a distribuição é muito homogênea mas
melhorou bastante
hoje seja não tem mais aqueles cursos
masculinos em que as mulheres não podiam
ou é não não se recomendava às para as
moças fazerem como engenharias foi
citado também será exatos é a mesma
coisa em todo o mundo o que o exemplo
que o editor da inglaterra nós temos
aqui no brasil continua 50 50 o número
de funcionários 45 o número de
professoras 40% já não está tão bom
porque se temos mais de 50% de alunas de
pós graduação porque quando a gente abre
concursos
o número de aprovados é menor
também existe a a a fase de acomodação
número mas quando chega a falar de
professores titulares
o professor titular es
esse número
ai pra menos de 30%
mas uma coisa interessante aconteceu na
hora que é dada a oportunidade eu vou
pegar as estatísticas que não eu não
tenho influência reitor um flip diretor
de unidade a unidade escolhe o diretor
o reitor apenas homóloga e da caída ao
posse pois bem dois a três anos atrás o
número de diretoras nós temos 42
unidades de ensino e pesquisa o número
de diretoras era só de 17%
hoje já contando a janaína
hoje temos 36 por cento o que a reitoria
fez apenas estimular incentivar as
nossas professoras titulares que são
menos de 30% a se candidatarem a usarem
dentro das suas unidades ocupa a posição
até a minha unidade que a escola
politécnica que quando eu era aluno
apenas um ponto da minha turma de 600 a
mão temos só seis alunas hoje melhorou
em 30%
temos uma diretora da faculdade de
medicina de ribeirão temos uma diretora
então até em unidades que eram
tradicionalmente vamos dizer muito
masculinas
temos diretores mas o que falar pra
vocês também que não podemos ficar
contentes com isso
tem muita coisa a ser feita
isto eu vou voltar a falar do que forte
isso não é somente responsabilidade das
mulheres é da sociedade
nós homens temos que participar
nós somos filhos
mulheres pai de mulheres companheiros de
mulheres amigos de mulheres
nós não podemos nos furtar e eu vou
dizer aquilo que eu aprendi nessa
iniciativa e forte
nós só vamos virar a página da questão
de gênero
se nós homens fomos feministas
obrigado
[Aplausos]